so I have done a ton of reviews of a lot
of different types of tech but one of
the things that I have always wanted is
an awesome home theater experience well
my friends today it is finally finally
happening with this nextigo Aurora Pro
pj92 projector and I cannot wait to show
this to you a huge thank you to Mexico
for sponsoring this video
why I'm so excited about this type of
projector it's a short throw projector
which will allow you to keep it really
close to the screen it's not something
you have to mount in a ceiling or have
it mounted this is legit
like I'm just going to be opening up a
movie theater in my home charging
admission at the door snacks you have to
buy them here I thought there was going
to be more setup but this is it
let's plug it in and I guess get it all
configured and ready obviously I have a
TV behind me and that's not an ideal
situation for a projector so can we get
a drum roll please
oh my gosh so now I'm gonna put this on
the floor close to the display which is
great because that does free up my
coffee table I am so excited I don't
even know what to expect
oh
look at you you look great so it looks
like we need to pair the Bluetooth
remote that it came with and it looks
like it's a pretty easy process we're
just going to press these two buttons
right here
and the remote was found it's connect oh
that's loud
so now it's giving me some instructions
to kind of get this all fitted to the
screen which I thought it had to be
further back but it's wild how close you
have to be oops sorry it keeps yelling
at me not to stare directly into the
beam which this is great because it has
an eye protection mode so we just have
to press a key
so this has two scroll Wheels on the
side that will allow you to adjust the
height of the feet so as you can see
here this is showing you you want to
reduce the height if the top is assorted
or increase the height of both feet if
it's distorted on the bottom rotate okay
yeah this is great I think it looks
pretty it looks good it looks spot on
now it's time to adjust the focus it
already looks pretty crisp but I have a
feeling that we can get even more crisp
so everything's all set up it's
calibrated and I was actually so
surprised how quickly and easy this was
to do there really wasn't much that we
had to change inside of the settings we
did adjust a few things and it's pretty
much perfect right now and I have one of
my YouTube videos playing behind me so
check this out oh wait before we do
let's dim the lights so we have a more
cinematic experience I also like that
the remote is actually backlit too so if
you are in a dark scenario such as our
cinematic experience that we're going to
be having here you'll be able to see all
of the controls so here we go
so here it is this
Pro pj92 projector this is
net Flagship Ultra short throw projector
that is the world's most advanced laser
TV it has breathtaking visuals a wide
color gamut Dolby Vision support
immersive Dolby Atmos audio precise
color representation 4K 120 hertz for
gaming and so much more I love how low
profile the actual projector is they
were really able to make this look so
slick and have it seamlessly blend into
any environment honestly for how
powerful it is it has a small and a very
minimalist design with the ultra short
throw capability this lets you place it
really close to your screen to reduce
clutter this has three HDMI 2.1 ports
with minimal latency and full support
for 4K 120 hertz input this is so wild
seeing my video that I made and shot and
edited on a huge screen like this in my
home I don't know I'm honestly
speechless right now okay so my first
test just watching some of my YouTube
videos was unbelievable and honestly I
can't even stress to you like how much
cooler this is than I thought it was
originally going to be obviously I've
seen a lot of projectors before I've
done reviews of TVs but this is on a
whole nother level because I've never
reviewed a short throw projector it's
just it's so Crystal Clear and it just
feels like I'm actually at a movie
theater but I'm sitting on my own couch
now again because it does have HDMI
inputs you can input any types of
devices that you have that are HDMI
compatible I have an Amazon fire stick
TV inserted into this so I'll be able to
watch all sorts of content on that you
can use any gaming consoles live TV
pretty much anything and you can plug it
right into the back and just switch the
inputs pretty awesome okay let's check
out this Dolby Vision content I'm so
excited the color on this is
professionally calibrated making it one
of the most color accurate UST
projectors out there I'm also really
surprised at how bright this looks even
in daytime it's 2400 anti-lumens that
will let you project a screen size from
up to 80 to 150 inches which is pretty
incredible it has a triple laser engine
that produces over 1 billion colors that
continues to give this true cinematic
color experience right out the Box
you're getting a professional color
calibration but if you go into the menu
you'll be able to further customize the
settings at 28 different parameters so
you can have that perfect visual setup
for whatever type of content you're
watching this also has enhanced contrast
with improved black levels with their
laser local dimming technology the audio
is also really impressive you wouldn't
think that this device would be capable
of such amazing audio but oh my gosh I
was so surprised with Dolby Atmos
support every sound is so realistic I
actually felt like I'm living inside of
a movie okay so now it is time to test
out gaming I'm obviously a huge fan of
playing video games so being able to
play games on a low latency display like
this is gonna be a really cool
experience I mean it's basically like
taking your console to a movie theater
and playing like that's pretty much a
dream come true oh my goodness okay I'm
so sad that I just stopped playing this
game to tell you about the performance
it was actually really really impressive
and one of the things when you are
playing games like this you don't want
to have a lot of controller lag I felt
like it was pretty seamless and I got a
few kills in my favorite first person
shooter game I think we all know it my
favorite game is so I'm beyond excited
about this setup it's been a while since
I've been like super hyped about a new
piece of technology and since this is
something that I've never really
experienced before I feel like a kid in
the candy store on Christmas Day I don't
know I'm so excited it's depending upon
the type of games that you play I'm a
huge fan of first-person shooter games
and I love having a fast refresh rate
since this does support 4K 120 hertz and
HDMI 2.1 you are going to be insured
that this is a gamer's dream like it
honestly was so fun and I can't wait to
play some more so far the experience of
using this projector and the screen has
been way cooler than I thought it was
going to be I have tested out a lot of
different Gadgets in the past but this
is something really new that I've never
really experienced before and until you
really experience a home Cinema
experience you haven't ever really
experienced it have I said experience
enough I'm not sure I just know that the
experience that I just had
I want to keep experiencing it forever
thank you guys so much for watching this
was honestly so much fun to test out if
you want more info or to purchase the
nextigo Aurora Pro PJ 92 projector check
out the link in my description again
thank you guys for watching and if you
haven't already please hit subscribe and
the bell to be notified when I post new
videos and I'll see you guys in the next
one I'm gonna go to the movie theater
now
I'll have to walk very far